Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Mi ricordo molto bene, quella sera:
avevo 19 anni, ed ero all’Università.
Ero così eccitato
da non riuscire a prendere sonno:
avevo appena avuto l’idea per un film.
Non dormivo perché mi stavo
già proiettando
all’anteprima del film
che in quel momento esisteva
soltanto nella mia testa.
Mi immaginavo una fila di persone,
fuori dal cinema,
che avrebbe riempito la sala,
e sentivo già lo scroscio
di applausi ai titoli di coda.
Non molto tempo dopo quella notte insonne
mi sarei trovato sul confine
tra Russia e Kazakistan,
di nuovo incapace di prendere sonno.
Ma quella volta per un motivo diverso,
perché sentivo che il film
a cui stavo lavorando
stava fallendo miseramente.
Sul momento ero troppo
desolato, per pensarci;
ma ora, guardando indietro,
la lezione mi è lampante:
essere troppo legati ai successi
comporta essere altrettanto
legati ai fallimenti.
Quella prima notte in cui
mi stavo immaginando il film finito
erano passati pochi giorni
da quando avevo conosciuto
un personaggio bizzarro:
l’unico abitante di Pozzis,
un paesino abbandonato di montagna
nascosto nel fondo di una valle.
Si trattava di Alfeo Carnelutti,
conosciuto da tutti,
da sempre, come Cocco.
Cocco è un uomo piccolo,
con dei baffi folti e degli occhi grandi.
Ha 77 anni, e un passato tormentato:
Soffre del morbo di Crohn,
e conduce una vita da eremita.
È un uomo che i suoi 77 anni,
nel bene e nel male, li ha vissuti tutti.
Ma Cocco, per indole,
guarda avanti piuttosto che indietro.
Tant’è che, quando le nostre vite
si sono incrociate, Cocco aveva un sogno:
partire verso est, con la sua
Harley-Davidson del 1939,
a costo di non tornare mai più.
Quella sera di diversi anni fa,
in cui non riuscivo a dormire,
avevo deciso che avrei fatto di tutto
per realizzare il sogno di Cocco:
saremmo partiti insieme
per quel viaggio assurdo,
e io ci avrei girato un film.
Avevo in mente una meta: Samarcanda.
E dato che uno dei miei film preferiti
era "Paris, Texas",
avevo già chiaro anche il titolo
del film: "Pozzis, Samarcanda".
Pozzis e Samarcanda.
Un paese fantasma, nascosto
tra le montagne del Nordest;
e la mitica città della Via della Seta.
In mezzo una distanza, non solo culturale.
Una distanza concreta, fatta di 8.022 km.
Concreta soprattutto
per chi, a oltre 70 anni,
guida una moto che di anni
ne ha più di 80,
ed è affetto da una malattia cronica.
Quando ho proposto a Cocco la mia idea,
mi ha detto di sì, senza battere ciglio.
Lui racconta che gli ho chiesto
di andare a Samarcanda
nello stesso modo
in cui avrei potuto dirgli
di andare a fare la spesa
nel paese vicino.
Un anno dopo aver preso
la decisione di partire,
ci siamo trovati qui, increduli.
Nel complesso, sentiamo di essere riusciti
nelle nostre rispettive imprese:
Cocco ha realizzato il suo sogno,
e il nostro piccolo film indipendente
è persino risultato, per alcuni giorni,
tra i dieci film più visti
al cinema in Italia!
Qui Cocco era a una posizione
di distanza da Anthony Hopkins.
Sulla piazza di Samarcanda,
ci siamo chiesti quale fosse
la morale del film che avevamo girato.
Per realizzare i sogni più improbabili,
bisogna essere abbastanza folli
da crederci, avevamo concluso:
se non fossimo stati
incoscienti abbastanza
da credere di arrivare a Samarcanda,
non saremmo nemmeno partiti,
questo è sicuramente vero.
Ma nelle storie di successo
è troppo facile non riconoscere
il peso che ha avuto la fortuna.
E noi, di fortuna,
ne abbiamo avuta tantissima.
Quindi non sono qui per dire:
credete nei vostri sogni.
E vi deluderà sapere che non sono qui
nemmeno per parlare di questa avventura.
Non è del viaggio in sè,
che voglio parlare,
ma di alcune cose
che ho appreso in seguito.
Voglio partire dall’incoscienza
che ci ha accomunati
il giorno in cui abbiamo preso
la decisione di partire.
Né io né Cocco avevamo idea
a cosa saremmo andati incontro:
Cocco non sapeva che strade
avrebbe dovuto percorrere;
e io non sapevo come dirigere un film.
Entrambi, di conseguenza,
abbiamo fatto moltissimi errori.
Ora, guardando indietro
agli sbagli che ho fatto,
mi è facile sorridere
della mia sprovvedutezza.
Allo stesso tempo, però, mi rendo conto
di come in quello spirito un po’ ingenuo
ci sia qualcosa che voglio conservare:
il fatto che non sapessi quale fosse
la strada giusta da percorrere
significava che, per me,
ogni strada era possibile.
Per esempio, quando siamo partiti
non avevo una sceneggiatura,
così durante il viaggio
mi sono trovato in difficoltà:
non sapevo come dirigere il mio film!
Alla fine, questo stesso fatto
è diventato parte della trama del film,
che prima di essere un film di viaggio
è un film su un regista
che cerca di fare un film.
Se avessi saputo in principio
il film che avrei voluto fare,
non sarebbe mai venuto
il film che è venuto.
Noi sarei mai stato in grado
di scrivere quella storia a priori.
Non potevo rendermene conto,
ma poi ho capito
che il mio non sapere era una fortuna.
E che l’esperienza che ora ho maturato
possa invece essere un ostacolo.
Perché la conoscenza
può essere problematica
quando mi impedisce di vedere
ciò che non conosco.
Sicuramente, l’esperto sa a priori
se una determinata strada da percorrere
è promettente o meno.
Ma per arrivare in luoghi
non ancora conosciuti,
occorre prendere la strada
che non conosciamo.
Ciò che mi auguro
è di fare tesoro
dell’esperienza che ho maturato;
ma allo stesso tempo,
conservare la mente libera del bambino,
che può permettergli di avere
intuizioni precluse all’adulto.
Tanto maggiore sarà la mia esperienza,
tanto più difficile
sarà ricordarmi di non sapere!
Ma non si dà conoscenza,
senza l’ammissione della non conoscenza.
Vorrei ricordarmi, sempre,
che sgravarmi del peso
della mia conoscenza
può mettere in luce
nuove strade da percorrere.
Abbandonare i propri preconcetti
richiede umiltà:
ma come scrive Claudio Magris,
viaggiare è una scuola di umiltà.
Anche fare cinema lo è,
ed in particolar modo fare documentari,
perché si fa presto a capire
che tentare di piegare la realtà
al nostro volere è inutile.
È più saggio vedere nel reale un amico,
il nostro aiuto alla regia,
e non un ostacolo.
Essenzialmente, ci sono
due approcci al cinema.
Il primo è quello
di Hitchcock, e di Truffaut:
questi registi ritengono
che tanto più il prodotto finale
si avvicina all’idea di film
che avevano concepito in origine,
migliore sarà la loro opera.
Il secondo modo di fare cinema
è quello di Agnès Varda, o Wener Herzog.
Per loro è vero l’esatto contrario:
il valore del film sta in quello scarto
tra film immaginato e film realizzato.
Solo lasciando spazio all’imprevisto,
riconoscendo la superiorità della realtà
e l’impossibilità di ingabbiarla
nei propri schemi,
si può trascendere l’idea iniziale.
Ecco che qui il cinema diventa ricerca
nella sua forma più pura,
il cui fine non è mai nell’esito
ma nell’atto stesso di cercare.
Hitchcock e Truffaut, inevitabilmente,
riterranno di aver fallito
in qualche misura,
perché ci sarà sempre uno scarto
tra film concepito e film realizzato.
Sono convinto di poter dire
che per Herzog, invece,
il fallimento non esiste:
anche un film fallito
porterebbe a un’altra storia,
rientrerebbe in un processo più lungo
in cui quel fallimento
rappresenterebbe solamente una tappa.
Fitzcarraldo, il film per cui Herzog
è più conosciuto, è esemplificativo.
L’eroe fallisce miseramente
nella sua impresa;
eppure, nella scena finale,
Fitzcarraldo ride,
perché riesce a trasformare
la sua sconfitta in un trionfo.
Anche noi sulla via per Samarcanda
ci siamo trovati sconfitti,
il nostro sogno infranto:
tra la Turchia e l’Armenia
Cocco è stato male,
è stato ricoverato in ospedale
senza essere più in grado di proseguire.
Ciononostante, abbiamo trovato
un modo per andare avanti,
per non rendere
quella sconfitta definitiva.
Sul momento, non potevo rendermene conto;
più tardi, mi sarebbe stato chiaro
l’insegnamento che avevo
tratto da quel viaggio:
il fallimento non esiste.
Successo e fallimento esistono
solamente in funzione di un fine
che mi sono prefissato.
Da quando ho capito che la meta
è solo una scusa per mettermi in viaggio,
non sono più mosso dall’idea
di avere successo,
e non ho più paura di fallire.
Prendere davvero consapevolezza di questo
è incredibilmente liberatorio.
Per noi Samarcanda è sempre stata
semplicemente un pretesto per partire.
Forse credevamo che raggiungerla
avrebbe dato senso al tutto;
ma abbiamo capito dopo
che Samarcanda non era la meta,
lo è stata tutto ciò che l’ha preceduta,
tutto quello che c’era in mezzo
tra Pozzis e Samarcanda.
La meta, per noi, è stata quella virgola.
Durante il viaggio,
sono stati pochi i momenti
in cui sono stato presente,
consapevole di ciò che stavo vivendo.
Ero sempre proiettato nel futuro,
ben oltre l’inarrivabile Samarcanda.
Stavo già pensando al film finito:
sarei riuscito a farlo?
Avrebbe avuto successo,
o più probabilmente sarebbe stato
un fallimento clamoroso?
Mi ricordo di un momento
in cui stavo lavorando
al montaggio del film.
Eravamo tornati da poco,
e stavo riguardando una scena
girata in un altopiano sterminato
tra la Turchia e l'Armenia.
Istintivamente ho pensato:
"Che posti fantastici,
vorrei andarci un giorno".
Eppure io lì c’ero stato!
In un attimo mi sono reso conto
dell’assurdità di questo pensiero,
e ho sorriso.
Ma dietro questo simpatico lapsus
si nascondeva una verità disarmante:
io lì non c’ero mai stato.
Lungo quegli 8.022 chilometri,
in quei 37 giorni di viaggio,
la mia mente era quasi sempre altrove,
a preoccuparsi di successi e fallimenti.
In quel momento avevo capito
che io quel viaggio non l’avevo fatto.
Di recente sono rientrato
da un altro viaggio,
molto diverso da quello
che vi ho appena raccontato:
un viaggio a piedi, da solo,
lungo la costa del nord della Spagna.
È stato il mio primo viaggio del genere,
ma ho fatto presto a capire un fatto
che credo sappia bene
chi viaggia a piedi -
e non a caso, Herzog
è un grandissimo camminatore.
Già dal primo giorno, ho capito
che il miglior modo per arrivare
era dimenticarmi della destinazione.
Se consultavo la mappa,
dovevo farlo solo per aver conferma
di essere sul sentiero giusto:
nel momento in cui guardavo
quanto avevo percorso,
e quanto ancora avrei dovuto percorrere,
l'intero viaggio diventava una tortura.
Così, gli unici momenti di contentezza
erano quando vedevo la meta vicino,
e qualche breve istante
una volta raggiunta.
Da quando ho capito
che ogni singolo passo era la mia meta,
che non c’era nessun luogo dove andare
se non dove già ero,
allora arrivavo senza nemmeno accorgermi.
Questa è la lezione più importante
che ho imparato ad oggi.
È di una semplicità disarmante:
ma ciò che è incredibilmente difficile
è vivere di questa verità,
ricordarla per ogni film,
per ogni progetto, per ogni viaggio.
Ricordarmelo ogni singolo giorno,
in ogni singolo momento.
Questo è ciò che mi auguro,
e che auguro anche a voi.
Uscire dai nostri schemi,
liberarci dai filtri
con cui ci rapportiamo alla realtà
è la sfida più grande in assoluto.
Ma possiamo ricordarci di farlo
in ogni momento,
anche solo per un istante.
Da questo dipende la nostra libertà.
E il mio invito è di farlo ora, tutti.
Io per primo.
Prendiamoci un attimo,
e ricordiamoci che siamo qui,
che siamo già in viaggio,
e che questa, questa,
è l’unica meta possibile.
Buon viaggio a tutti.
(Applausi)